according to the European Commission 6.6
million EU citizens lived and worked in
a member state other than their own in
2012 but they're still facing
discrimination and difficulties working
abroad MEP voted to clarify the rules on
freedom of movement for workers to
unleash the full potential of the single
market having in mind that the inside
European Union we have two million
vacancies and on the other side so high
unemployment rate probably higher
percentage of moving workers could be
partly sold the situation now MEP s will
start negotiations with national
governments in the council to make sure
that workers moving abroad can fully
exercise their rights MEP s go to the
pictures tonight in Brussels to watch
the films competing for the lux prize
the hopefuls will be screened in all 28
EU countries as part of the lux film
days the lucky winner will have their
film adapted for the hearing or visually
impaired the head of the culture
committee behind the prize is proud of
the e u--'s investment in the silver
screen you can see a lot of films which
gotta rotted with high prices at the
beginning so got some money to start
from the one of the films in competition
the broken circle breakdown will also be
Belgium's entry for the Oscars and will
be screening in brussels on november
seventh
from flemish director Felix Bana königin
it tells the story of alize indeed ye
whose love is tested when their daughter
is diagnosed with a serious illness